first and foremost happy New Year to
everybody and welcome back to a new
edition of I Dida Ann Arbor as usual we
like to acknowledge numb focus for
sponsoring our events TD Ameritrade for
offering us up their space to use for
our data and also for my desk at the
University of Michigan for providing the
food here important points especially
for people who are new here are the
emergency exits there's an emergency
exit right out front here and also the
doors that you just came in right to the
right of it is stairs to get down please
do not use the elevator in case of fire
again we're always soliciting for
speakers throughout the year so please
reach out to us if you're interested
giving a talk and I think that in April
we're gonna try to aim to do another
series of lightning talks so look out
for that sign up as well so those are
the I think we're either gonna be
shorten it up a little bit and make sure
that I do a good job limiting the number
of people that we have although we we
appreciate the enthusiasm as always Ben
and I are looking for feedbacks or
anything that we're doing right but more
importantly what are we doing wrong
right or things that we can improve on
we'd love to hear any of that feedback
and also everything that we that we
talked about is posted on our github
page so go and check that out and you
know for respect to Scott make sure that
if during the talk unless the question
is quick please hold it until the end of
the talk and also remember that you're
in a borrowed space so please clean up
after yourself I'd like to read the
pineda code of conduct so Partida is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race or religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communication should be
appropriate for a professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meetup
events be kind to others do not insult a
put-down other attendees behave
professionally remember that harassment
and sexist racist or exclusionary jokes
are not appropriate for pineda
attendees are violating these rules may
be asked to leave the meetup at the sole
discretion of meetup organizers thank
you for helping make this welcoming and
friendly an event for everybody and more
importantly I also want to point out
that you know we're very happy to have
two high schoolers here joining us from
from a nearby school Widow and we're
we're very happy for everybody to be
joining us in fact a quick icebreaker so
considering all this frigid weather here
today's icebreaker is turn to somebody
either on the left or right and tell
them what your favorite season is of the
four season then why and introduce
yourself so go ahead
[Music]
here will have met somebody new with
similar interests and as always we'd
like to talk about the this month in
data sire
so that my pick this month is part 8 so
if you haven't heard of Part A it's a
data storage format I guess file format
so if you have columnar data you can use
park' so instead of using CSVs you can
use Part A and it's really good for
reading and writing really quickly
there's also metadata and it's recently
introduced into data frames in pandas so
we can do a DF to park' or REIT RK and
you can read these files and this was
nothing implemented by West McKinney so
check that out and also where is Logan
so Logan ahlstrom over here
Logan's team is hiring a data scientist
an intermediate level data scientist
right so I've been interested please
chat with Logan after the talk and then
finally next month very excited thanks
to dr. Patricia over here Schuster
dr. Schuster TD Huff is coming into town
so KT was actually a keynote speaker at
PyCon this past summer and she's going
to be talking about doing our best
practices doing our best practices is it
open reproducible scientific computing
and that's on Thursday February 15 a day
after Valentine's Day so hopefully
everybody can can make it up for that
with that I'll let then introduce Scott
and I'll go to Scott and have you turn
on your mic
yes oh stop seaport and I met he's
really active in the computing community
w Madison hopefully we get to see a
number of funny cartoons that make us
feel smarter thank you okay I'm Scott as
Ben gave the nice introduction I would
like to thank Ben Incheon both for
having me here this is really nice and
I've had a pleasant experience so I
would talk about crowdsourcing machine
learning in cartoons but before I get
started I want to mention a couple
things first of all this crutch there
the first question I tore I partially
tore my ACL skiing a week and half ago
then a week ago I was I had planned a
ski trip but I couldn't ski so I'd to
watch everyone else ski well I was on a
crutch which is annoying the second
thing is I'm a grad student at
uw-madison I study optimization machine
learning which is why I'm giving this
talk I'm also a STC Bert's on Twitter
and github and that's important because
the last thing I tweeted oh excuse me
the last thing I was going to tweet but
I forgot too was a length of these
slides but that I know I know that link
is too long so I there's a shorter
version and that sort of version will
appear in the bottom right on every
slide after this I feel I get too
anxious about this okay so I'm gonna
talk would it be the piece of software
you wrote it's called next the reason
it's interesting is because it's a
moment to and pure Python and it enables
research by producing a better results
with with the same budgets time or money
or whatever okay so the problem next
solve is one of data collection in
machine learning so machine learning as
the current state of in the open of the
current state of machine learning is to
assume that the data has already been
collected do a bunch of complex
mathematics to produce summer
what we said is if the data collection
process is expensive and costly we may
want to use some of that mathematics and
machine learning to help us out and help
reduce the cost of data collection okay
and so the the place where we the the
place where we saw this was a problem
was in crowdsourcing because you'd pay
people for their time or money to answer
a bunch of questions and so so we had
some applications where we wanted to ask
humans a bunch of questions but paying a
bunch of questions like you know
Millions
so it was expensive in terms of you know
we'd pay them for their time that was
expensive what I mean by this is so
here's an example of the cross hosing
problem so when you see your rules I'm
not a robot prompt you don't know you
don't know it but secretly you are a
crowdsourcing participants because what
happens is done so you see this prompt
they ask you to type some numerals that
show the image you type two five zero
hit verify and go on your way but what's
really happening is they're collecting
all these responses and feeding them
into some machine learning pipeline to
train a machine learning model to
predict exactly what you did so given
given another image of you know I gave
you seven five nine instead of two five
zero they want to have a scene learning
about model to take the image that
predicts seven five nine so your
response is being used and some
crowdsourcing experiments to generate
some data set you have a question all
right
III saw are there any questions on what
right right right I mean yeah so so this
is they've made some wonderful datasets
but I'm not Google right I don't have
access to millions of users that visit
my webpage every single day I can't do
that I don't have those resources so my
goal is to achieve the same thing at
Google
but with minimal responses you know cuz
I don't want a piggy pool I don't have
the time or I can't baby I can't pay
people for the responses right okay so
how do we do this so so this so this
system right here is something we call a
passive system it says I want to ask
these questions it asks those questions
and it gets some results right so in
this case it says but I won't ask
questions you know two-five-zero it
collects those questions the humans and
produces some machine learning model one
way to so require a fewer responses is
to adapt through the result that's
produced so so this is putting the human
in the loop in some sense right it's
saying you know given given the result
you see which questions are most
important you know you're asking the
high value questions okay so so the main
benefit behind this is that we can
require is that we can require fewer
responses to achieve the same results so
our goal so our goal of the goal of our
software there's to adapt to previous
responses to achieve this goal - to
adapt the previous responses to require
a few responses all right so the main
benefit behind this is that the data
collection cost with adaptive systems is
far less than past the system's
so here applauding the data collection
costs on the y-axis and the problem
difficulty on the x-axis and we see that
for very easy problems passive and
adaptive algorithms are about the same
for very difficult problems or very
large problems passive our adaptive
algorithms or adaptive algorithms are
much cheaper than passive algorithms a
quick example of this a quick example of
this is with sorting so let's say I'm
using a passive
or like a doubly nested for loop that
required order n-squared responses by
using the daftest or like quicksort
it requires on average order and log n
responses which is much less and that
and that that's a result that's
characterized by this curve so existing
existing crowdsourcing systems are
passive by definition because they don't
know that the the the callback required
to a valid question importance based on
previous responses our system does which
is why we're a doubt whipped this is why
we can be adaptive and other systems are
by definition definition passive I mean
so next can run a passive a passive
algorithm really easily just you know
it's a next is a superset of the passive
systems I guess in some sense and so
this has very real benefits it enables
so though the reason next was created
was because a psychologist came to us
came to us with some very difficult
problem and they couldn't do it with a
passive dog and it cost too much money
and they went to ask high-value
questions we built the system and we
enabled their research and they
published paper often
okay so I've sell a lot of words and I
feel like I'm not making very much sense
all right but here's an example of what
I mean okay so let's say we're
collecting labels of fruits on two
different axes maybe you know height and
weight or something and we affected you
know labels of apples and oranges and we
can begin to awesome classifier
represented by this blue line that's
that separates the two right now the
thing next does is it chooses where does
ample next so so you know so we asked
the question what point would give us
the most information and at that point
is represented by this red dots because
that this because this is the point that
we're most uncertain about right it's
the closest to this the to the decision
boundary so you know this is the point
that has the highest probability that
like we're unsure right it's like
halfway between the apples and oranges
we're not sure
and this point is different and after we
learn that after we learned that as an
orange our classifier changes pretty
dramatically so that's what I mean by
requiring fewer responses if we had
collected as a point that was very far
away from there's a decision boundary
our classifier may may not change at all
so we want to adapt the previous
response to adapt to previous responses
to find the truth quicker does that make
sense
all right good because that's what our
software is based off of that's where a
software goes but it does this in the
crowdsourcing context so our software is
called next because we want to ask the
next best question or we want to ask the
best question next
but anyway so it was created it was
created by Kevin Jameson and Rob Nowak
professor Rob Nowak who's my PI with the
help of law Jane but the work in this
talk will be a work that Daniel ross law
chain and I did we made it easy for our
collaborators to use I'd also like to
thank our funding sponsors without these
groups or software would not be possible
oh and I should add we all work for Rob
at some points I'm the only one left
everyone else who found a bigger and
better things
although working for Rob is is fun and
all that I shouldn't I shouldn't
diminish that so our software is pretty
widely used it's used all the way from
machine learning theory all the way down
to practitioners an example of the
machine learning research is with the
Air Force Research Lab they're using our
software I can't really discuss what's
it's classified I think but I can
discuss the practitioner case which so
the New Yorker is using our software for
a very practical a practical problem so
the problem they have is that each week
so is there cartoon caption contest so
each week so I so each week they receive
a cartoon from like virtual nests but
cartoon doesn't have a caption so they
asked their readers for funny captions
they received something like five
thousand captions of which you have to
find the funniest one this is a very
difficult a very difficult problem right
if there's a lot of captions and humor
is the forcely difficult you have to ask
humans so with it like so with I say
something oh yeah so this is a problem
meant for a depth of data sampling
because it is a very difficult problem
and using a path so we've done
experiments on this using a passive
algorithm you can't find the funniest
caption with any confidence using an
adaptive algorithm you can we want to
enable that and turns out we do our
software now runs this caption each week
this contest each week it's available at
these two URLs but here the interface 3%
is shown here so we say here's the
cartoon and here's one caption you can
write that caption is unfunny somewhat
funny or funny and after you do the
caption turns great for a while and a
new captain shows up now there's a lot
of math behind that new caption and how
it's how it's chosen but the intuition
is pretty valuable and it's so so our
goal is to find the funniest caption
getting it really only makes sense
that's where the funny captions if
something has been rated as unfunny you
know nothing about in funnies is
probably not that funny and we probably
shouldn't ask about it right I mean so
something like two thirds of all
captions are unfunny why do we we don't
want to waste two thirds of our human
response budget on clearly unfunny
captions we don't want to do that so
this is an interface we present to you
so they're crowdsourcing participants
this is the interface we present to Bob
Mann cough he cares about the funniest
caption so we show up a list of captions
rated by funniness we also show some
other information like like for this
contest reflected about half a million
responses and we see that Bob Mann cough
sent an email to this interface right
about here
as you can imagine this data is really
valuable especially for a machine
learning research lab like I work in so
we've reportedly we've been running this
contest for about two years now
we've collected some naked 33 million
button clicks to over four hundred and
forty thousand unique captions over like
ad contests or something this is super
valuable that cannot be ignored I'll
mention more of this later
but first I want to show you the
funniest caption because I couldn't
cheat you otherwise yeah so that's the
funniest caption but I'm not gonna
mention another points so the first
thing we notice is that our software
works our software requires fewer
responses as illustrated by this graph
so the green line there you kids it's
hard to see but we require four times
fewer responses this is huge our
software works this is what Bob Matt
Koff cares about we've also collected
some other valuable information we for
one we have some more insight on what on
what the and how funny the captions are
right so most captions are very very
unfunny the funniest captions lie around
this one point there's only is it's it's
I don't know what that says and so so
the next thing we see is a little is a
little more academic you see that some
more some some of the violations we make
are not satisfied some of those
sometimes we make are violated that's
why I'm going to say so we assume that
every response is iid or it's in two
independent and identically distributed
meaning that we assume that the
probability of reading something is
unfunny is the same no matter who you
are how many captives you've seen
whatever it's all the same however we
see that as you see more and more
captions you get tired and you're more
likely to write things as unfunny that
violates our assumptions our algorithm
should not work in this case all right
as no guarantees that finding the
funniest one
so this is a problem the next thing we
see
so we've generated some you know two
papers from this that mentioned
specifically this data set and the last
point is the most important one our
software now works at scale so for the
first year and a half you're running
this as an experiment something you know
that you know it'd be nice if it works
you know for large scale but now it does
so now the New Yorker can publish can
can put this on their front page don't
quote me put up a put this on their
front page and you just can go to it you
know five billion users can go to it and
our software phone fail it uses some AWS
lambdas yeah this is nice and and this
entire slide speaks for a larger goal
our larger goal is to connect the
adaptive sampling algorithms with
crowdsourcing so I mean both have other
uses like crowdsourcing is used all over
in psychology and adaptive beta sampling
is used in like radar and medical
imaging and all this but there is some
intersection how do you want to enable
adaptive data algorithms in this in this
intersection so we want to tell the
crowdsourcing the people the people who
use crowdsourcing hey you need fewer
responses you want them to give us our
gate to give us their data and the
problems they see with it we want to
enable this why because arguably some of
the deepest insights and greatest
innovations come through experimentation
we want to enable this this is this is
incredibly valuable both to us in to
them this is this is huge it's this
feedback the only way to do that so we
found in practice is to build a piece of
software and that's what we did now in
order for this video coop to exist two
things have to happen the software has
to be useful and has to be easy to use
because otherwise people won't use it
right and if people will use it they
won't talk about it and they won't use
it for other experiments which is what
we want and as to be easy to use by both
the crowdsourcing community and the
people who write algorithms
I'm gonna mention both of those later
but first I want to mention why how it's
useful so the first use case is with New
Yorker cartoon caption contest and in
this we say you can rate one item as
three buttons or it can be yet n buttons
in general you've got a 15 buttons and
said I don't see why you would but you
could and the one item I mentioned so
right now we're rating a piece of text
the caption you couldn't you could rate
you know a video an image a piece of
text a gif
whatever anything HTML can display
anything that pops up and it pops up in
your web browser
we call this interface Cardinal Bandits
that's what it's referred to in the
literature our next use case and we have
adaptive algorithms for this by default
our next use case is with dueling
bandits and ASCO two items instead of
one item we have adaptive algorithms by
default that choose they can find the
best class the best item in some set so
for example this is asking you to select
my computer so right by comparing two
items so in this use case we're trying
to find the safest streets by asking
which tree looks safer this is very
similar to sorting but it's a little bit
crowd sourcing makes a little tricky how
much more of this later so the third use
case we have is useful in generating
some similarity metric so so let's say
you want some similarity map of faces
you know you want all the happy faces in
one place although unhappy faces in
another this is useful for that because
we say which of the bottom two items is
most similar to the top item we have
adaptive algorithms for this by default
not much more of this later Oh point out
this use case specifically and then so I
should also mention that we have a we
have a REST API so you don't have to go
through our web interface you can just
use its you can send JSON back and forth
this is other New Yorker interacts with
the interaction with our system
and so we have so this has seen use in
practice so we have seen use by by
psychology labs computer science labs
our lab in at uw-madison we've also seen
use from other companies I don't know if
I can mention their names but I can
mention what feels they work in so one
is with social media and one is with
insurance and one is with military we
have we have seen a lot of use this has
seen traction it is easy to use that's
the main reason so now I want to mention
ease of use for the crowdsourcing and
experiments lists this is you if you're
if you want to use next this is you so
the interface we present for the
crowdsourcing experimentalists is we all
we require is a web browser and an
Amazon account
alright Amazon AWS account that's all we
require so after you make an account you
go to their elastic cloud computer store
ec2 then you click on a nice big blue
button that says launch an instance
that's what you want to do you want to
launch an instance with our software and
you find our software and our our Amazon
machine image or something or operating
system you select our ami and then you
can figure a couple other small details
like if as a memory if the choose
already instance you have to open a
couple ports it's not huge and there's
more to feeling the documentation but I
but this is all we require now you might
ask well shouldn't to run your software
shouldn't have to download some code or
something and yes you can you absolutely
can and it runs via docker it runs with
I think three commands it's pretty
simple so after you after you launch
next you see you see an HTML page that
this that says you know here's the state
of next it says here's the list of all
your running experiments but you haven't
launched anything yet so hello that is
an experiment launch and
when you click on that link you see this
page this page requires upload of two
files one is a zip file of your targets
or your your objects and it's subscribed
more in the text there but the other
file is more important it's perhaps
harder to describe the other file
describes the state of the experiment
you want to run so describe you know
Cardinal band is doing bandits full bass
triplets and it's it's really not clear
what should go in this file
I mean like what format is this file in
so if you go back to the previous page
and click on documentation or examples
it shows you what exactly should go in
that file
there's Akkad this is this is documented
inside checked so this is this has to
work if it's said here it has to work
and so you see that you have to have
some key you know called participant to
algorithm management and then if you if
you wonder like oh hey watch these
values be by default I guess you can go
back and click on the examples on github
and see an example of that file this is
all that's required and we've seen use
of this in practice so it is pretty easy
to use for the crowd sourcing
experiments list I would I mean it so I
gave a talk at Syfy this last summer and
someone in the crowd someone from a
social media company in the crowd saw my
talk was like oh hey that that might be
useful so I took it back to the company
I'm one of their half-days they launched
our software and started using it and
now it's being used in practice so it's
super cool so now I want to mention so
that's all I mentioned for ease of use
for the experimentalists now I'm going
to mention ease of use for the algorithm
developer this is me in my day job right
I like oh hey I haven't do it I knew it
after bagger them let's try it on and
see how it works before I go any further
are there any questions on anything I
wrote earlier okay i yeah it's open
source and free I don't know that's a
mistake
it is
well even worse we went to the New
Yorker and they asked us oh hey you know
how much how much do you want us to pay
for this software and we said it's open
source yeah I know miss opportunity but
I mean with money comes responsibility
so okay so now ease of use for the
algorithm developer this is me my day
job
so any adaptive algorithm requires more
functions I mean one function is for
initial initialization and one function
is for getting results it's not that
important most of the time in an
adaptive algorithm is spent here so here
so we so we call it gate query every
time you want to see a new caption and
we call a process answer every time we
click on the caption so the question is
so that's all in adaptive algorithm is
it's just these four functions and the
question is how do we design these
functions what choices do we make so
that's the next slide hissa
what choices do we make and then what do
we what have you started enabled and to
show this I'll show three specific use
cases of you know of people in our lab
that have done something novel and
interesting because our system is easy
to use so the choices we make the first
choice we make or the they have the
first choice we make is using a
high-level language like Python because
it allows developers like me who only
care about math I'll block here about
more well only care about math to write
down what they want in code pretty
easily using numpy or any of this not
anything like C which would be hard the
next point the next point the next thing
we do is we treat algorithms as black
boxes so this allows some for some some
a petition that has an adaptive
algorithm has two adaptive algorithms to
say oh I want to unplug one and put
another one in or compare them
side-by-side or something like that this
is really easy to do why
because in practice all this means is
that the inputs and outputs are
documented and take checks
so for example it's some function called
gate query might expect some strain
called participant ID and my return sum
the index of some caption to ask about
that's that's all we require there's
inputs and outputs nothing more and so
another thing that's nabel's is it
allows you to do whatever you want and
whatever tools you want to so you can
call you know tensorflow of hi george
numpy whatever we don't care
all we care is the inputs and outputs
you can do whatever else you want so the
second choice you make is we notice that
most adaptive algorithms almost all
adaptive algorithms have to store state
and they have to run background jobs or
that's a store State and they have to
update some internal model so we give
some nice wrapper for this to allow us
to happen we called the butler because
it helps us it's pretty nice
the third choice we make may seem
trivial but we abstract objects to
integers so we so if you're asking what
I'm 42
we don't you only know that you're
asking about I'm 42 you don't know that
you're asking about the the text you
know the answer it's a life life the
universe and everything and I mean this
is important and this is like how I
think about it this that we test and
plus there's a mapping from imagery or
soft details so I don't know why you
change it although you can if you want
but so so the next thing that's valuable
for the algorithm developer is the
dashboard the dashboard is incredibly
valuable because it describes how well
your game is doing and if we had more
than one algorithm in this in this use
case like right now we only have doesn't
work
KL you see B it's shown in the below
rankings right there
if we hit more algorithms those are just
more tabs so we can pair them very
easily so and these
these are the results we can see the
results easily however we can see more
information for example we can pair the
timing of all about the algorithms you
know so this you know for each of the
four functions you know this is how long
each of those took we can also see more
information we also have some fly inside
timings so we can see how long the the
crotteaus weirdest man was waiting for a
caption or how long they how long they
are waiting for a caption or how long
they took to respond to a rate to
certain caption and then you can even do
some more advanced stuff like testing on
the holdout sets we also support that
which is incredibly valuable for a
algorithm developer like me okay so
that's how easy it is to use for the
algorithm developer now I'm going to
mention three use cases that illustrate
how that because of the ease of use for
the outgunned developer these choices
have been enabled Sarah mention these
three choices these three experiments so
so these J experiments what not to do
with shoes and finding the right shoe
for Hugh um which is a critical task the
next one is finding a safety of City
Street safety of city streets in Chicago
and the third task has to do something
with faces and some psychology
experiments I mean I'm no I mean so the
psychologist I mentioned that next was
created because of this so the reason
they were it was created was because the
psychologist wanted some yeah they they
they wanted some a low dimensional
similarity map of facial emotions so
they wanted so so we can see that all
the really joyful faces are up at the
top all the really happy pieces are
right here and I don't really know why
they wanted this but they wanted it
uh-huh
specifically two psychologists Tim Tim
Rogers and April Murphy they came to rob
Nowak and kevin Jameson and I said oh
hey we want to do this can you help and
then was it the help of law and they
built a system
and they decided on the question the
simplest in terms of working memory to
be a comparison you know so you know
which is the bottom two faces facial
emotions is no similar to the top base
facial emotions so if you saw it
if you thought these two base facial
emotions were more similar you would
select this face either with clicking on
it or with the right arrow this is the
problem that works best with working
memory like I could ask you know given
you know which of the 15 bottom faces
are most of the top face but my working
memory is not that good maybe yours is
we I mean we could we could also have
people to like you know drag around
faces on some similarity map but like
what are they good mean so this is the
simplest example the main problem with
this is that the number of fights so
given a number of faces the number of
questions feels poorly so if you if you
have n faces you have about n cubed
questions to ask possible questions to
ask this is difficult because finding
the best questions becomes challenging
like you may be asking like something
that doesn't even make sense
like what's more similar to hope a
giraffe or a space shuttle that doesn't
make any sense right like a fight so
finding the best questions becomes
really challenging especially when there
are many faces so this problem is
actually really interesting
mathematically and we've generated a
couple papers out of it these are only
the algorithm developer papers
none of these except for the last one
are really application papers but most
importantly we have solved the
psychologists problem they ask for some
map of facial motions and we made them
so we see that all the all the angry
faces are in the bottom left and all the
really happy faces are in the upper
right now if you look at this I mean I'm
no I'm no psychologist so don't quote me
so I looked at this and I was like
oh I see two dimensions I see an
intensity mission and a positivity
mission so like boredom is over here
fury and surprise are up there happy and
joy are on the top of the positive
positivity axis and unhappiness another
end so that's the motivating use case
for next we solve this problem
another example of something we solved
was one of is we hold this street score
and it was reading the safety of city
streets in Chicago and we wanted to see
how humans perceive that and how they
actually matched the you know the crime
rate in that in that in their area where
that street was and so we were
interested in so some collaborators are
you Chicago we're interested in showing
pictures of streets pictures of streets
in Chicago I'm seeing which one was
safer now the best way to do this again
working memory it is by asking which of
the two streets looks safer because I
have a hard time reading the safety of
city streets just with one image I post
this is more interesting mathematically
so they they use Google Street view
images so they can map the perceived
safety of city streets on to the actual
safety of city streets based on the
crime rate or homicide rate or whatever
now the problem with this is that there
is a clustered ranking i I don't think
of you know oh this street has a you
know a thirty nine point one risk of
some crime happening I think no no this
is a safe Street this is a somewhat
savory or this is unsafe for you that's
really about it there are some
advantages to this such as it's very
similar with sorting which is a
well-studied problem and so maybe this
will help and so so then the question is
how do we overcome this issue of
clustering ranking in the presence of
crowd sourcing and so we've generated
paper off that and so they they they
gave some algorithm for a cost
ranking in crowdsourcing Samhita is the
main eats cat areia is the main person
unless she's one of my lab mates he had
the help of law chain in creating this
algorithm and the collaborators at
collaborators at UChicago
were in Donna and James Evans and of
course we had the help of Rob RPI Robin
Oh Mac but so again I'm not gonna get to
the math of the algorithm but what they
do is pretty interesting so they say so
let's say we have two groups a safe a
safe group in an unsafe group
represented by that dotted line there
now we want to ask about points because
we have a cluster ranking we will want
to ask about points that were most
uncertain about that could possibly lie
in the other boundary another bucket so
so the point the points with the red
arrows are the points that were most
uncertain about and could possibly lie
in another group the right so I'm
plotting street safety by street index
and they're sorted by default it doesn't
matter it doesn't really matter in
practice or functionally but and then
the bars or confidence intervals so so
we see that for for the point on the
very far left with red it's its mean its
mean is the lowest in the other group
and it could it's most possible to line
that in the unsafe group okay so notably
at first glance we don't see any gains
from adaptive algorithms so here I'm
bodying the fraction of of pairs that
got wrong versus the number of responses
and we see that that the error rates or
the fraction of this is is the same for
an adaptive algorithm and a passive
algorithm this is really concerning it
means that this is a really easy problem
or something we don't see any gains from
active learning so when so Sammy gave
his prelim in this November I think and
when Rob asked the question who studies
that you know Rob Novak who studies
active learning he spent his whole life
doing this yes you know oh hey why don't
we see any gains you know should the
study of
I study this this should help right and
Smith's answer made a lot of sense it's
you know the answers are pretty noisy
there's not much active learning can do
it's just it's an easy problem because
they're so noisy so but if but if you
look a little closer our our algorithm
was in trying to get complete sorting
and look at that look at the safest of
any streets it was saying which it had
some groups right so within each group
they were completely set completely the
same so if we look in this case if we
run some simulations where we actually
have well-defined groups we see that an
adaptive algorithm outperforms a passive
algorithm which suggests that in the
street case that our adaptive algorithm
actually had benefits so we couldn't see
that from the actual error rate this
game is kind of subtle okay so the third
example is with image search I'm gonna
so let's say we're thinking of some
eschew however let's say we're trying to
find the right shoes some shoe that
looks like that but we have to go to the
Zappos database which is many many shoes
and we can't really do it so we're gonna
ask yes/no questions of do you like this
shoe or do you not this is very similar
to the cartoon captions but then the
main thing behind this is that we had a
large database of the entire Zappos
shoes 50,000 of them and so every time a
user clicked the button we had to go
search over the entire data set and it
took 1.2 seconds I was honest it took
and I optimized it as far as like code
systems
it took 1.2 seconds so I got it down to
that for the next question to appear
which is too far on the web which is too
long in the web context and so I mean so
I opted Mises as far as I code systems
but Cuong here he optimized this from
the math perspective which is he changed
the polymer party he changed the problem
we're trying to solve he do this along
with rudy who
this is his problem and Robin though I
came back a will it both help out with
this but the main thing they did is they
said instead of exhaustively evaluating
all shoes in the data set you know woman
shoes men shoes kids shoes they said
let's just selectively evaluate some
shoes so if you chew if you chose red
boots maybe they were an example I think
they would they would evaluate this
function at the union of red and boots
or maybe the intersection whatever they
they have some mathematical thing
mathematical technique for this to prove
gains now they've generated some
real-world results with this with real
human data and they see that their
method would shown in purple there has
similar reward to two other adaptive
algorithms so here I'm plotting reward
versus number of human responses and we
see that there a purple thing doesn't
perform super well but doesn't perform
super bad however this plot is hiding a
dimension it's hiding a dimension of you
know how fast did you get a response
right so I mean so it may be that the
purple or the blue and red lines they
think you know may take ten seconds with
the algorithm to respond which is not
really suitable on practice so from all
from all these use cases we have seen
some software in-house enhancements
we've spent you know this has been my
job to improve the software however
before I leave I mean so these are
enhancements but before I leave I want
to leave with a couple key messages so
the first one is that adaptive data
collection can reduce the cost of data
collection the second message is that
next is a crowd sourcing tool that
enables adaptive data collection notice
I did not say that next will reduce your
data collection costs I mean it in in
general and with high probability it can
do no worse than then before then in the
passive case and you may see benefits
but you may see benefits I
now say you will see benefits that's a
very important distinction our system is
not magic it can't do what know what
nothing can do the third message is that
next is easy to use by everyone involved
notice I said easy to use with a star
next is a piece of academic software
that was created out of collaboration by
easy to use I mean that our
collaborators are not interface every
week asking questions I mean and I
should stress that next is pretty easy I
mean it has been used by other companies
I mean I gave a talk of sci-fi and
someone in the audience was like oh hey
this might be useful with our problem at
our company let's use it and they did it
in less than a day this is good all of
you could probably use it too
and the fourth message is that we build
next to enable this feedback loop to get
feedback both to aid our research and to
improve our software so so this person
that I gave this the person that started
using our software after sci-fi she
talked to me she said hey we're using
your software I said great here's our PI
and here's a couple other mathematicians
that helped create next and now one of
them is helping them with their problem
this is perfect go look at the paper and
show solve our problem optimally this is
perfect so please sauce it using your
system like we have a whole getter
channel on or read me
we want to hear about your problems this
will help everyone involved so with that
thank you and I guess I'm asking for
questions
[Applause]
[Music]
so how do you so your Hetrick
implemented say I trained on the
generator Ditka said a classifier and
see which classifiers basically seeing
responses yeah that's exactly the
benefit and we have a test for that so
yes so the question let me rephrase that
the question was how do I tell how do I
tell if the dap the bhagam is better
yeah yeah in a machine learning yeah in
a machine learning context so the way
you can tell us by training on a holdout
set and you would see that as the number
of rows Rafa's increase are quite our
system will have lower holdout test it
or lower test error no no so we don't so
so we do support having like three
outcomes by default so so you would you
would collect one dataset randomly is
look because your test dataset you look
like one dataset just as a pass dogger
if i'm my dataset as an adapter go them
I knew a test on the hold outside half
after and after you run your experiment
to completion so the question was what
classifiers do you provide by D laws
yeah so so perhaps I should have made
this more clear so we supports using
anything you like to make her adaptive
algorithm so you can use all of s scalar
and you can use all of fight or excuse
whatever you want all we care about are
the inputs and outputs of anything and
so
there is a function called get results
and what she would you know reproduce
the results a you know my classifier I
produce this error yeah all right early
in your presentation bandit yeah so so
we so it came from bandit so so this is
the case of the alright so we think
about multi-armed bandit where some
bandit walked into a casino and he has
multiple arms to pull on multiple slot
machines he wants to pull the slot
machine that gives him the most reward
for the most money and so that's what
comes from yeah yeah I'm sorry about
that in the real world in New Yorker did
they choose what and present the
funniest do they choose and present to
the public the funniest the funniest
caption so you're asking so after after
for the after it's all done and
basically and do they actually always if
they do that do they always choose the
top one or do they sort of like no
because humors of various subjects right
so so the question was how does the New
Yorker choose the funniest caption do
they always choose the funniest one and
drain the buyers our system or they
choose the fifth one is rated by our
system and the answer is I'm not sure
that's a New Yorker not me that's
internal for them I do know that before
our system was you know before two years
ago they have some intern rating the
funniness like grouping captions
together and really good funniness and
then they had some whole rule-based
system so we are improving so so past
our system I'm not sure I believe they
true they look like the top 10 or
something and you know it it narrows on
the list easier for them we are
improving their humor beacon because
because we're saying you know it's it's
easier for them it's better for them
it's you know it's easier for them they
find the right answer quicker they you
know it's not some intern anymore and it
produces the right was all and so we do
have theoretical guarantee
he's that the the the funniest caption
should always rise to the top and we
have we do food for any repeats be
include that caption twice and we have
cm you have seen both captions flow to
the very top one in spots 1 & 2 so our
our theory has been shown to work in
practice which is kind of cool there was
a scenario where someone was reading a
comic and then I think what you said was
the next time around that would not be
used surface to someone to review
because it's been marked as not funny
right right but if the case was just
that the distribution of funniness that
person was on some fire extreme and most
people actually thought it was funny
yeah so the question was what if what if
some strange person doesn't need a
caption is funny and he says unfunny
even though everyone else thinks it's
funny right yeah all right
so ever you caption so all the bounds
hold a very high probability so all the
theoretical bounds hold with high
probability meaning if there's very low
probability of someone coming in and
answering that or that's what we assume
now in practice every caption is rated
at least 16 times yeah so there's 16
people would have to at least screw this
up alright mentions it with you are
using EWS lambda right or some or
perhaps all of these things could you go
into a little bit of depth about what
your experiences were doing that with
yeah so I like innocent directly it
wasn't me that was using a because it
was Liam Marshall on law attainment this
it's like yeah I can't say anything with
them experience I can't say that not so
next is not a little bit
Sanders we said this captioning contest
is specific to it needs to work at scale
how can we enable that and that was with
so only the caption contest runs in a
bit of AWS name so the question is
Lucy's is doing better than humans do
are there any ethical implications of
doing this I think this is this is so
I'll give you the developers answer so
this is the tool you can use it forever
whatever you want to if that's not the
goal
III don't think rating graduate students
would be ethical that but as a graduate
student I problems with that because
it's not far off from waiting street
they're on the sea right right there
could be tons of bias he's doing yeah
and even I was questioning the question
asked about whether or not the street is
safe if you're being very literal about
it presses seeing cars and inferring
that a rusty car is that safe or unsafe
or low-income or all right another thing
I've noticed is that if the picture is
cloudy you're more like the rate is
unsafe oh yeah oh how much
so the question is there's a lot of work
out there that saying you know
bihter kurz are only know only this good
you know they may answer the question
too quickly or something maybe when I
prune those responses out or weight them
less importantly and is there anything
built in for this and no there's not not
right now but you can enable it pretty
easily because every so there's a
participant ID for every question that's
asked so every time you press the button
some persons know that some random
participant ID gets sent back the next
so you can see if the same person is
answered the same question more than
once and you brought up another point I
forgot to mention so the psychology
users up next the main users of the next
perhaps they the way they use it is they
[ __ ] some demographic information via
Mechanical Turk and they send that they
send them a link to next the answer on
to the answer a bunch of questions on
next and then it displays their person
to the participant ID which the
psychologist can see in the responses
they paste that back in and paste that
back into mechanical turk so it can be
used with with passive crowd sourcing
systems so I think well we'll leave it
at that
let's all give Scott another round of
applause
[Applause]